drôle de sapins et drôle d'ange dix
artistes ont revisité ses
traditionnelles décorations des fêtes de
fin d'année pour le noël décalé de la
commanderie
l'exposition entièrement composé de
matériaux de récupération s'est ouverte
samedi dans la chapelle
c'était un peu notre rôle de proposer un
noël différent à noël avec des artistes
à elle avec des amateurs noël avec aussi
des parents enfants puisque on a aussi
des propositions en famille notamment un
atelier lantern flottante
durant deux heures les enfants
apprennent à construire leurs lanternes
avant d'éteindre la lumière pendant la
fée 12 des feuilles en tout et on a on a
on a collé tout fuir la mine passe-t-il
on a mis du polystyrène en dessous et
puis on a mis une bougie des lanternes
qu'ils pourront déposer sur la pièce
d'eau de la commanderie samedi 15
décembre avec tous les participants de
l'atelier à les enfants ça super content
en sabrant pas cher et puis une
construction qui s'est fait à la main
avec eux pour leur âge c'est magnifique
les festivités se poursuivent et
s'intensifient jusqu'au 16 décembre avec
des concerts des stands solidaire et
même des activités plus surprenante
nous aurons un sauna alors un sauna
mobile à la manière du bagnard ruche
donc une petite caravane qui va être
placé à côté de la pièce d'eau de la
commanderie où vous pourrez venir faire
un vrai sauna entre amis trois places
possibles le nouvel décalé de la
commanderie est présent jusque dans la
cour avec un arbre à mot auquel
participent chaque visiteur